Chris waters here with a gamespot news
update today Epic Games announced that
they've started work on a new Unreal
Tournament game and that it will be
entirely free upon release according to
their announcement development on the
game began today may eight they plan to
develop the game quote in the open as a
collaboration between Epic Games Unreal
Tournament fans and unreal engine 4
developers to the extent that the full
code for the game will be available on
github Epic Games added quote will
eventually create a marketplace where
developers modders artists and gamers
can give away buy and sell mods and
content earnings from the marketplace
will be split between the mod or content
developer and epic that's how we plan to
pay for the game only two months ago
Epic Games co-founder Tim Sweeney said
no new Unreal Tournament game was in
development okay yeah sweetie I see what
you did there you little son of a [ __ ]
we'll be keeping an eye on you and you
folks can keep an eye on Unreal
Tournament as it develops right here on
gamespot